that's a very interesting and a very
difficult question because um at some
point I decided that what shapes me up
is a portable world that I can take with
me everywhere I go because I I stayed in
Iran till I was 13 and then I was sent
to England and to Switzerland elated to
the United States to continue my studies
so from a very early age the idea of
going back home I think that the strange
thing about Iran for me is that the idea
of returning to Iran has shaped me more
than the idea of being in Iran you know
and then when I went back home I
realized home was not home because I
went back to the Islamic Revolution you
know and the best that it has given me
has been the memories of addictive
culture the poetry I think that is what
I most identify with the start of the
revolution I was in u.s. then I was
writing my dissertation actually when it
happened
in 1979 and and as as luck would have it
I finished my oral defense the summer of
1979 and I went back so I wasn't there
for the very beginning but I was there
for you know pretty much from the start
of it and I left Iran in 97 so I was
there for 18 years
well you know when I was in America I
was part of this very huge student
organization was sort of international
by international I mean Europe and us
mainly student movement which was at the
time against the Shah looking back on it
I I do understand our stupidities
actually I cannot find a better word for
it not because we wanted a better and
more democratic political organization
but because in trying to gain that we
ourselves were not more democratic in
our manner you know we were very radical
marxist you know in in in the worst
sense of the word in many ways you know
and and so we didn't see the pitfalls I
so at the start of the revolution it
wasn't Islamic it was sort of people
from all across the board and the the
slogans were mainly very secular and
Anna and we felt that there is going to
be a serious change but right before I
went back to Iran I had already become
disillusioned because of because of
Ayatollah Khomeini and his fatwas and
his edict like for example again about
women so when I went to Iran I had my
hopes that the extremists won't win but
I also was very worried so from the
beginning the hope was tinged with this
illusion or despair
you know leave leaving so early and
leaving the people you love the things
you miss about her the places you well
in this case the things you miss about
home are all in the details like the
mountains surrounding Iran Tehran the
city I was born in that that that makes
me always homesick the way in Tehran it
snows and then the Sun comes out you
know so the idea of home was always very
strong because I left so early you know
and I would go back for summer vacations
but that would only make it worse
made me want to go back more I just felt
first of all I never knew that
what happened would happen I you think
few did and I thought that this is the
time to give back you know the I have
been sent abroad I've gotten the
education the time for me now I finished
my work my studies I need to go back in
those days when you would go back there
will be so many others who are coming
back with you in the airplane and you
know once the plane was over the city
people would start singing songs and and
you know many exiles were returning many
people you know we returning with a lot
of hope that is how my husband and I
returned and we had just married you
know when we'd gone back the very first
scene in the airport brought to me the
frightening ideas that I later
experienced because Teheran Airport was
always a place of joy since childhood
it had lovely restaurants and coffee
shops where we would go as children
have I screamed there it was always a
social place and and they had a
restaurant where I think it was Thursday
afternoons young people went there to
dance it was called head down head down
son you know during tea time you would
go for dancing so it was a very joyous
and sort of communal place not just the
place where people departed and arrived
and the first thing that I noticed in
the airport was the somberness there
were women there veiled and in black
head to foot there were people with guns
they were make posters of Ayatollah
Khomeini and other Islamic leaders with
slogans against America and Britain and
the West as a whole and and rather than
welcoming they were searching our
suitcases not for weapons for alcohol or
you know so there wasn't any welcoming
back you know that was the first
impression but there was still a lot of
excitement in the air especially because
I went directly to teach at the
University of Tehran that had been the
seat of so many struggles from 30 or 40
years before the Revolution it was a
very sacred place for many Iranians and
for me I mention it in my book had I
been offered a job in the best
universities in the world I would not
have felt the awe that I had felt about
going to University of Tehran and that
excitement was still there in the
mornings there would be heated debates
between various factions everybody had a
table you know different groups so it
was a very lively place still despite
the disquieting signs
you know on the side alongside of this
excitement already they had started
doing things which were a terrible the
the first thing was the executions very
brutal executions of people they
connected to the old system and and some
of the people who who did belong to the
old system were also among the best not
everyone was stained and that system was
better than this way anyway you know in
many ways they had started closing down
the progressive newspapers in early 80s
I think it was 1980 or 81 they started
coming down on the universities because
the universities are so secular and they
were just seat of protest all the time
and they had a sort of a Chinese style
Cultural Revolution where they said they
needed to close down the universities
for an indefinite number of years until
they were purged and you know became
Islamized
so we were both the faculty and the
students protested and there were
sit-ins all-night sit-ins and protests
many students were jailed and and some
were murdered
they were we I remember we used to
demonstrate the streets of Tehran at
some point the vigilantes the Islamic
regional entities who started hacking
wood wood knives and and and with stones
and you would disperse and then some of
the unlucky ones would be arrested and
you wouldn't know about their fate you
know so finally they did that they
closed down the universities and started
a very very serious purge and they
didn't start until those purchases were
done they never got what they wanted the
universities remained basically circular
and the Islamic students who at first
had expelled people like me became like
you know
you